how does chess compare to the Tour de
France the way that chess is like the
Tour de France it would be that you're
trying to strategize you're trying to
plan ahead so certain games you're
trying to pick on certain opponents per
se is very similar to that this is very
popular events I mean chess and the
people who love just like his Tour de
France okay it's cycling I think it
lasts quite long and it's very very
tough spot also because well you need to
be prepared very seriously and you need
to not only be strong physically but
also mentally I think like in chess I
actually once was witnessing the finish
of Tour de France at shams ELISA I don't
know maybe classical chairs can be
compared somewhat with this cycling
because it's also very boring you'd see
it and it goes on day after day for many
hours or so but rapid and blitz maybe
it's more like the cycling in you know
indoor yeah of course there are some
parallels but cycling as it is is a real
team sport and the teammates are as
important as the leaders and but the
strategies I put in place of course
require definite syncing before before
the way starts and also during the race
itself to adjust to any events there are
a lot of room for creativity when you
compare sports in particular chess and
I'm sure cycling also ten years
many comparisons even football and
hockey I believe but we Kramnik was
comparing his style against Garry
Kasparov with the hockey team we claimed
he was inspired by by the hockey team
well yeah in chess in long classical
chess games you you really need to have
a lot of mental endurance you can't get
tired you can ruin everything in one
move like you can you can play
brilliantly for five hours and then in
one second throw it all away so you have
to have that mental endurance to make
sure that if you have a bad position you
defend it in the sixth hour or if you
have a good position you convert it